ce type que nous allons poser dans une
démocratie moderne la presse doit être
pluraliste indépendante et pour remplir
ces deux conditions économiquement
solides j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir
dans une démocratie moderne le secret
des sources est protégé par une loi qui
prévoit des sanctions pour ceux qui la
violent aujourd'hui impunément dans une
démocratie moderne les journalistes ne
sont pas convoqués sous prétexte
d'atteinte à un secret défense qui ne
cesse de s'étendre
la raison d'état est souvent une très
mauvaise raison dans une démocratie
moderne un président de la république
tient régulièrement des conférences de
presse pour expliquer son action la
fabrique de la décision relève à nos
yeux de l'information légitime aux
citoyens dans une démocratie moderne
enfin des médias ne sont pas poursuivis
pour violation du secret des affaires
aucune de ces exigences est utopique
elle existe ailleurs entendons nous bien
ses fondamentaux ne sont pas le combat
d'un vieux monde il n'épargne nullement
notre secteur et notre profession des
enjeux et des défis auxquels nous devons
faire face nos audiences quel que soit
le support sont prises dans une bataille
de la tension aujourd'hui une bataille
ou l'outrance et les contre vérités sont
toujours plus forte nos modèles
économiques sont trop fragiles face à la
puissance démesurée des géants du
numérique qui continue malgré des
avancées de captain au contenu et la
valeur de notre travail les aides à la
presse sont importantes et nous saluons
leur pérennité mais elles ne peuvent
arbitrer cette concurrence déloyale nous
nous sommes en la matière félicité trop
tôt de la loi sur les droits voisins sa
philosophie est très importante son
application est difficile
l'autorité de la concurrence l'a rappelé
aujourd'hui les plateformes doivent
rémunérer des médias pour la diffusion
de leurs contenus au terme d'accords
passés de gré à gré les géants du
numérique finance aussi des médias pour
qu'ils relèvent et corrige les fausses
informations fait news qui ironie de la
situation sont propagées par ces mêmes
plateformes sans arbitre et les
discussions entre les organisations
professionnelles concernées nous
relevons deux effets pervers dans cette
nouvelle relation entre la presse et les
plateformes
cette dépendance financière ressemble
fortement à des subventions
malheureusement discrétionnaire et non
pérenne alors que c'est un travail un
travail et une audience qui doivent être
justement rémunérés second effets
néfastes des médias deviennent les
producteurs d'une information qui se
voudrait une vérité absolue une forme
d'informations officielles contre les
fake news que ce soit de la part des
plateformes ou des pouvoirs publics cela
nous ne semble pas de nature à faire
baisser la défiance vis-à-vis des
journalistes la presse ne peut devenir
un sous-traitant de moralité des
institutions qui veulent bien faire
toutes ces plateformes irresponsable les
journalistes ne détiennent pas la vérité
ils cherchent à établir les faits à les
comprendre et à les faire connaître
c'est une quête par définition toujours
imparfaite nous ne sommes pas exemple de
critiques tout comme la fuite vers des
bulles de désinformation d'une part de
nos lecteurs auditeurs téléspectateurs
doit nous interroger la liberté doit
rester cependant la règle absolue pour
exercer notre métier une liberté bien su
recadrer par la loi sur la presse et à
laquelle nous répondons le cas échéant
devant les tribunaux mais pour être
libre et indépendante la presse doit
aussi être viable économiquement pour
assurer nos revenus les législations sur
les services numériques à l'échelle
européenne sont porteuses de solutions
elles doivent être soutenues et elles
devront s'accompagner d'une
indispensable transparence pour les
citer google et facebook cherche et
chercherons toujours à contourner les
régulations et les réglementations et il
nous faut aussi évoquer aujourd'hui bien
sûr les concentrations en cours dans
notre secteur pour être totalement
transparent je suis dans un média
concerné par une fusion et pour ôter
tout soupçon d' auto-censure ou debout
de conflit d'intérêts je précise que je
m'exprime au nom de l'association de la
presse présidentielle face à ces
concentrations l'une des premières
conditions de la pluralité est l'égal
accès c'est le principe d'une économie
libérale ouverte comme la nôtre l'égal
accès aux marchés de tous ses acteurs y
compris quand le marché change
singulièrement de périmètre cela vaut
pour les plus grandes rédactions comme
pour toutes les autres sur un même
terrain de jeu il faut se battre avec
les mêmes règles dans l'univers
numérique dans lequel tout le monde
diffuse désormais les mêmes règles ne
s'appliquent pas à tous en particulier
pour le secteur de l'audiovisuel qui
garde un encadrement contraignant qui va
bien au delà de la loi sur la presse la
pluralité n'est pas seulement assurée
par le nombre de médias mais aussi par
la diversité des lignes éditoriales
enfin dans cette période électorale nous
voulons rappeler à tous que s'attaquer à
la presse est facile que cela peut
servir des intérêts électoraux ces
attaques abîme la profession et
fragilise la démocratie pour me répéter
la presse est un pilier de la démocratie
sans presse libre et indépendante
il n'ya plus de démocratie
voilà donc avec la la réserve que nous
impose la période ce que nous pouvions
exprimé comme voeux pour cette année
2022 vive la liberté de la presse nous
vous remercions monsieur le président de
cette écoute l'association de la presse
présidentielle vous souhaite quelles que
soient les échéances une bonne année à
vous à vos proches et à tous les
personnels de l'elysée
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs merci pour
pour romo et pour vos voeux et à mon
tour
j'étais avec quelques-uns à
quelques-unes d'entre vous tout à
l'heure pour une conférence de presse
que j'ai donné comme la semaine dernière
avec le président charles michel c'est
un dom tom de manière régulière
et donc à celles et ceux que je n'ai pas
encore vu bonne année tous mes voeux
tous mes voeux
à titre personnel de bonheur
d'accomplissement tous mes voeux aussi
de prospérité de développement pour les
rédactions auquel vous appartenez et mes
voeux de progrès pour la liberté de la
presse en france et dans le monde et je
vais y revenir je rejoins vraiment ce
que vous venez d'évoquer à l'instant à
titre de préoccupation ou d'inspiration
la situation sanitaire que nous
connaissons toutes et tous nous a
conduit donc à à renforcer certaines
contraintes a annulé les cérémonies
traditionnelles et merci d'avoir accepté
tout à la fois que ce rendez vous se
tiennent ce que je crois dans son
utilité et bonheur de nous retrouver
même s'il est moins convivial et un peu
plus réduit dans sa forme que qu'à
l'accoutumée
alors
avant toute chose pardon du contexte et
en parlant de la crise sanitaire au fond
je voudrais insister sur le fait que le
contexte tout à la fois sanitaire et et
politique au sens générique du terme n'a
jamais
justifier
un tel besoin de presse et de presse
forte libre indépendante au moment même
où votre secteur votre métier est
attaqué par plusieurs grandes
transformations que vous avez largement
évoquée résidant
en effet rarement
n'avons eu autant besoin d'une presse
forte libre indépendante capable de
hiérarchiser les informations
de distinguer le vrai du faux dans le
pluralisme et par là la maïeutique que
vous avez rappelé une série mode de dire
qu'un titre de presse un journaliste à
la vérité mais que la déontologie qui
anime votre profession permet de bâtir
la vérité par un système de vérification
et un dialogue permanent en faisant
référence à des sources et à des règles
qui sont les vôtres
de raconter le monde de manière éclairée
rarement oui nous avons eu autant besoin
de journalistes parce que cette pandémie
si je puis dire est la plus parfaite
illustration de cette nécessité
s'empresse nous n'aurions eu
d'information à la fois ni sur le virus
ni sur son évolution et la vie de la
nation de manière libre à orchestrer
alors j'entends aujourd'hui parfois
certaines ou certains fatigués des
débats permanents
dire que tous ces débats sont terribles
je crois au contraire quand je regarde
l'état du monde que les démocraties
pluralistes ou la presse peut rappeler
les faits éclairer le débat ces
démocraties ont plutôt mieux réussi que
des systèmes autoritaires 100
journalistes libres que les autres alors
oui il ya des moment d'interrogation sur
des questions qui est existentiel dans
une pandémie oui il ya des débats oui il
ya des contestations et c'est normal
c'est la vie d'une démocratie mais nous
avons vécu durant cette pandémie quand
on se compare est qu'on prend en quelque
sorte de pas de recul nous fait que nos
démocraties par ces débats éclairés ont
permis sur le virus la manière de
traiter le virus d'organiser la vie de
la nation ont rappelé l'importance
d'une information
libre et éclairé
sans presse sans le travail de
vérification des informations auxquelles
vous vous livrez
les vagues de fausses informations de
cette news pour reprendre l'anglicisme
parfois convoqué par certains de mes
anciens collègues avec une autre accepte
notre exception et les fausses
informations donc aurait été plus
puissante et plus dangereuse encore
et nous avons vu d'ailleurs ce que vous
avez appelé ses bulles de désinformation
des phénomènes complotistes qui sont
encore là mais on ne les fait douter en
eux les des cons truites par un travail
d'éducation d'une part mais également
par l'animation d'une presse libre et ce
dialogue permanent ces vérifications
permanente s'empresse l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes n'aurait tout simplement
pas eu accès aux détails des mesures
prises pour confiner des confiné
instauré un couvre-feu en appeler aux
gestes barrières aux autres et au delà
de ce travail d'information libre de ce
qui constitue le débat démocratique
d'une nation auquel vous contribuez je
veux aussi saluer toutes les initiatives
civiques qui furent celles de la presse
et des journalistes durant cette période
pour n'en citer que quelques-unes et
pardon pour tous les autres collègues la
chaîne france 4 qui durant le premier
confinement s'est transformée en salle
de classe géante plusieurs titres de
presse écrite presse quotidienne
régionale et presse nationale aussi
qu'ils ont publiés des attestations à
découper et ont reçu pour l'habituelle
grand prix des médias en 2021 tout ça ce
sont des gestes qui au delà du rôle
d'informer
constitue le fait que vous êtes dans la
vie de la nation avec ce rôle civique
est essentielle pour cela pour cet
engagement ce rôle que vous avez rempli
et remplissait dans cette épreuve
historique au service de l'intérêt
général je tiens à vous remercier
rarement donc nous n'avons eu autant
besoin de la presse et pourtant rarement
depuis 1880 et les lois fondatrices qui
organise votre profession et votre
secteur la presse n'a été autant
fragiliser
je veux ici dénoncer évidemment avec
force les menaces qui pèsent sur
l'exercice de votre métier d'informer
partout dans le monde
les chiffres réunis par reporters sans
frontières sont malheureusement là pour
le documenter avec 46 journalistes tués
en 2021 et je veux ici vous dire
combien la nation tout entière
évidemment est mobilisée aux côtés
d'olivier dubois et de sa famille et je
vous remercie d'avoir parlé de lui et de
l'avoir ici citer comme un de vos
confrères qui en exerçant sa profession
d'informer mais en se rendant sur un
théâtre dont nous connaissons la
sensibilité le danger a été prise en
otage je veux ici dira d'abord le
soutien de la nation toute entière à
lui-même et à sa famille faut dire que
le travail inlassable et menée par nos
équipes diplomatiques nos militaires et
les services compétents en la matière
vous connaissez ma très grande réserve
sur ces sujets pour donner plus de
détails ou trop de détails et je l'avais
fait pour madame petrona en son temps
mais je veux que vous soyez ici certains
et certaines que nous sommes pleinement
mobilisés pour oeuvrer ans au libéra
sion en tout cas nous ne l'oublions pas
et nous faisons tout pour permettre sa
libération et nous sommes aux côtés de
sa famille
mais au-delà des chiffres que j'évoquais
du cade monsieur dubois une augmentation
de la répression d emprisonnement dans
certains pays sont en croissance
soutenue le métier de journaliste est
bouleversée partout y compris dans de
grandes démocraties par une conjonction
aussi inédite de phénomène
le modèle économique de votre profession
d'abord est battue en brèche par
l'avènement de grandes plateformes de
l'internet et de la société du tout
gratuit vous l'avez parfaitement dit je
reviendrai sur plusieurs
points que vous avez mentionné la
révolution numérique ensuite change
profondément la production même de
l'information
là où elle est et le monopole de
personnes formées pour cela aujourd'hui
chacun smartphone à la main ou clavier
au bout des doigts peut s'improviser et
je pèse mes mots journalistes
et la diffusion des nouvelles enfin
s'est elle aussi totalement
métamorphosée là où les rédactions
notamment dans la presse écrite prennent
le temps de sélectionner les unes les
titres les manchettes là où les
kiosquiers dans la rue prennent un soin
particulier organisé leur devanture là
où les rédactions à la radio comme à la
télévision débattre longuement de la
priorité donnée à telle ou telle
information dans l'espace numérique
organisé par des algorithmes opaque en
flux continu c'est l'émotion qu'on
privilégie bien souvent sur
l'information celle émotions négatives
la plupart du temps qui est privilégiée
sur l'émotion positive et c'est aussi la
possibilité offerte
d'orienter l'accès à l'information par
le biais de ses algorithmes pour des
raisons ou financière ou idéologique etc
l'espace offert à des manipulations par
des puissances étrangères qui n'ont
d'autre but que fragiliser la nation la
vie démocratique
comme le dit un de vos confrères la
presse de plus en plus c'est donc devenu
je le cite entre guillemets un combat de
rue je cite là eric fottorino
et ce mouvement est inédit parce qu en
quelque sorte il vient bousculer la
diffusion la production et l'orientation
même le travail rédactionnel qui est le
vôtre
si je tenais à m'exprimer devant vous
c'est aussi pour prendre l'engagement
que la france continuera d'être
rendez-vous de ce combat qui touche ce
que nous sommes profondément c'est à
dire une nation de liberté de raison
éclairée par les lumières
alors en 2022 nous serons comme nous le
sommes depuis le premier jour au
rendez-vous de la défense de la liberté
de la presse et de l'accès à
l'information pour tous en effet dès
2018 lors du forum de paris pour la paix
nous avons lancé avec quelques autres le
partenariat international sur
l'information et la démocratie
43 pays cinq continents nous ont
rejoints et je ici saluer le travail
remarquable de reporters sans frontières
et la poursuite de ses travaux depuis le
début en novembre dernier en présence de
la vice présidente des états unis
nous avons renouvelé notre engagement
nous avons surtout constater combien ce
partenariat avait permis d'avancer
l'idée d'un new deal pour les
journalistes
sommet annuel pour l'information et la
démocratie à l'onu la création d'un
observatoire qui sur le modèle du giec
aura un rôle d' alerte sur ce fléau
moderne que sont les infos des mis tout
un écosystème de progresser mis en place
à travers plusieurs initiatives qui se
sont consolidées depuis 2018 et nous
devons continuer en nous donnant les
moyens de soutenir les médias d'intérêt
public une autre annonce faite lors du
forum de paris cette année fut la
création du fonds international porté
par votre concert journaliste maria rsa
prix nobel de la paix et je souhaite que
celui-ci puisse jouer un rôle
catalytique en quelque sorte avec le
plein soutien de la france et donc nous
sommes en train progressivement tous
ensemble de construire les mécanismes de
protection de réarmement en quelque
sorte de nos démocraties face à tous les
phénomènes que nous venons l'un et
l'autre successivement de décrire et
vous pouvez compter sur mon plein
engagement pour continuer à mener ce
combat pour la liberté d'informer et
combat qui est
je dirais d'autant plus efficace qu'il
est comme vous le faites porté par
l'ensemble des journalistes partout à
travers le monde et dans toutes les
sociétés
à chaque fois d'ailleurs que j'ai des
entretiens avec les dirigeants de pays
je mets sur la table ce sujet
egypte turquie iran chine je ne serais
pas ici
exhaustif par définition mais partout il
ya des journalistes qui sont menacés
emprisonné empêché dans leur travail je
considère que le rôle de l'union
européenne et de la france est
évidemment de citer ces cas d' obtenir
des libérations nous en avons encore
obtenu récemment et de permettre de
rétablir un cadre normal l'action je ne
suis pas naïf nous y arrivons
quelquefois nous avons parfois ensemble
réussi délibération heureuse
mais seul le travail démocratique
justement permet d'avancer de changer le
cadre dans la durée à chaque fois que
des journalistes sont menacés par un
changement de régime comme récemment en
afghanistan 40% des médias ont disparu
en seulement quelques mois je le dis
pour celles et ceux qui pensent que nous
avions affaire à de nouveaux talibans à
des gens beaucoup plus ouvert à un
régime démocratique avec des pratiques
nouvelles 40%
des journalistes ont disparu depuis le
mois d'août la france leur offre un
refuge sur les 400 afghane et afghans
protégé par la france un tiers sont des
journalistes
j'avais annoncé en juin que la france se
doterait d'une fondation dédiée à
l'accueil des combattants pour la
liberté aux quatre coins du monde et je
suis fier que la fondation marianne est
ainsi été créés le mois dérnier ici à
l'elysée elle pourra notamment abriter
les journalistes inquiétés dans leur
pays et les défenseurs
de la liberté de la presse
sur ce combat nous ne céderons rien
c'est un combat pour les libertés
mais c'est un combat
pour le modèle dans lequel nous vivons
tous et toutes ici réunis dans cette
salle
est là aussi prenons deux pas de recul
je pense que sur beaucoup de sujets
beaucoup des géographies que j'ai
évoqués il ya dix ans nous n'aurions pas
pensé une seule seconde à voir
quelques-uns de ces combats à conduire
dans plusieurs des pays que j'ai évoqués
et je pense que ce combat est
existentiel parce qu' abandonner c'est
part de liberté dans des pays amis
parfois voisins ou qu'ils étaient des
pays pour les uns complètement
démocratique en tout cas qu'ils allaient
vers la démocratie c'est acté d'hercule
et laisser prospérer l'idée que nos
valeurs en particulier les grandes
libertés publiques et individuelles qui
sont de l'effectivité des démocraties
libérales au sens politique du terme
sont des valeurs relatives
régional qu'on pourrait renvoyer en
quelque sorte à une parenthèse
historique sur un continent données ce
qui est un recul
historique pour le coup par rapport à la
situation nous étions il ya encore 20 à
30 en
parlant de ce combat je veux ici vous
dire que nous ne céderons rien non plus
quant au combat pour toutes les libertés
y compris celle de terry capturés et
vous savez d'ailleurs combien en france
le gouvernement comme moi même avons
toujours pris des positions claires au
risque
de parfois suscité le courroux
les violences et les menaces
pour défendre ce qui est une liberté au
coeur de notre démocratie une liberté
constitutive de notre république cette
liberté de caricaturer la satire le
dessin d'humour le dessin d'actualité le
dessin politique sont au coeur de
l'histoire de france et je le crois très
profondément de la vitalité de cette
liberté de la presse là aussi il disant
cela je ne parle pas d'une évidence
quand tant d'autres démocraties y
compris les plus grandes ont par des
mécanismes presque naturel une sécrétion
par culturel
effacer le dessin de presse de certaines
de leurs rédactions
je suis fier pour ma part que ce ne soit
pas le cas en france et je pense que
nous devons continuer de le défendre
avec force il ya deux ans je m'étais
engagé à lancer une mission pour étudier
la possibilité de créer une maison du
dessin de presse projet porté par
georges wolinski depuis longtemps
flambeau repris avec ardeur par son
épouse maryse qui vient de nous quitter
de journaux dont je veux ici saluer
l'engagement et la mémoire la pandémie a
ralenti ce projet mais les études ont
progressé les consultations se sont
poursuivies plusieurs options
d'implantation été sérieusement
expertise et dans différentes villes et
nous avons entendu les écouter les
aspirations
des projets et sept maisons
internationales du dessin de presse
verra donc bien le jour et ce sera à
paris dans un bâtiment du 6e
arrondissement jean fed annonce ici je
vous remercie madame la ministre de la
culture pour sa mobilisation et le
travail conséquent de l'ensemble de ses
services et d'elle-même pour expertiser
toutes les options possibles je sais la
déception de quelques villes de province
qui étaient quand à tout à fait sérieux
et donc nous aurons des projets
culturels grande ampleur alternatif mais
je crois que tout concourait à ce que
cette maison puisse être actée pour
paris les travaux commenceront dès que
possible en partenariat avec la mairie
de paris et la région ile de france et
je veux remercier la mer et la
présidente de du conseil régional pour
aussi leur action aux côtés de la
ministre d'ores et déjà deux millions
d'euros sont prévus au budget 2022 du
ministère de la culture pour permettre
la naissance de cette maison qui sera un
lieu d'échangés de débats de formation
d'exposition en étant basé à paris elle
travaillera en réseau avec un ensemble
de partenaires en région en europe lui
tout comme ailleurs dans le monde est au
coeur de paris l'esprit du 11 janvier
celui de cette marche qui lie à 7 ans
tout juste a rassemblé des millions de
personnes pour la liberté d'expression
continuera donc de vivre
en 2022 nous seront aussi au rendez vous
de l'accompagnement du secteur de la
presse dans sa mutation économique que
vous avez évoquées depuis cinq ans
l'état à préserver amplifier les aides à
la presse
conformément à notre tradition et je
dirai au delà d'ailleurs de toutes les
alternances à chaque fois que la
situation était critique nous sommes
intervenus pour venir au secours des
segments en difficulté le sauvetage de
presstalis en 2018 puis de nouveau en
2020 les mesures d'urgence dès le début
de la pandémie le plan de relance de la
filière presse depuis l'an dernier la
création d'un crédit d'impôt pour
favoriser les abonnements ou encore la
réforme du transport postal de la presse
je n'oublie pas par ailleurs le fonds de
lutte contre la précarité des
journalistes créé par le ministère de la
culture destiné notamment aux pigistes
qui ont été particulièrement fragilisées
par la crise avec 36 millions d'euros
versés sur deux années je n'oublie pas
non plus les photographes que nous avons
souhaité soutenir de manière inédite par
le biais d'une grande commande
photographique piloté par la bnf
ce sont deux sans faute aux journalistes
qui vont être sélectionnés leurs travaux
vont permettre de constituer une sorte
de radioscopie de la france
d'aujourd'hui car l'histoire s'écrit
aussi en images je voulais remercier
d'ailleurs tous les photographes qui
sont présents que journaliste et qui
accompagnent en permanence la vie de la
nation et notre activité plus
modestement mais qui font aussi ce
travail d'informer et d'éclairer
et qui sont aussi
importants pour ce que l'un et l'autre
nous défendons depuis tout à l'heure au
total le soutien de l'état à la filière
presse représente 483 millions d'euros
depuis 2020
je le dis c'était une nécessité je le
dis aussi parce que ce n'est pas partout
une évidence et sané compris à travers
l'europe a partout une action
systématique
nous continueront d'accompagner votre
changement de modèle car la presse n'est
pas seulement un marché qui répondrait à
une logique comptable
c'est un bien commun qui relève de
l'exigence démocratique et citoyenne
c'est pourquoi je suis heureux du combat
que nous menons en europe puis dans
notre pays ce combat pour les droits
d'auteur et les droits voisins je
remercie la ministre de la culture pour
sa mobilisation dans tous les cénacles
européen mais
ce combat là aussi n'a rien d'évident
mais je crois que c'est la vocation de
la france de le conduire notre pays a
toujours défendu les hauteurs de
beaumarchés à genevois jusqu'à malraux
nous avons bâti le modèle économique les
textes de lois pour protéger nos auteurs
puis l'ensemble de nos créateurs et nous
avons réussi je le dis avec les grands
textes européens que nous avons fait
cheminer à européaniser le modèle
français
parfois nous ne critiquons nous
quelquefois peut-être critiquons nous
collectivement à l'excès je contribuais
ce défaut
autant constitutifs de l'esprit français
mais il faut que nous soyons fiers de ce
que nous arrivons à faire collectivement
quand ça n'est pas là non plus une
évidence
rémunérer les auteurs et les droits
voisins n'était pas une évidence dans
les textes européens ce fut une bataille
homérique nous avons importé et c'est
une avancée considérable
maintenant il faut que celle-ci puisse
se concrétiser complètement la france
s'est aussi illustré en appliquant
beaucoup plus vite et plus fortement que
les autres mais je regarde comme vous
les choses et nous allons devoir
cheminée aller au bout de l'application
dans sa substance parce que rien n'est
évident qui consiste à appliquer des
textes
lorsque la symétrie entre les acteurs
est si forte des acteurs si puissant si
riche si monopolistique qui peuvent
menacer du déférencement vous dire on va
discuter de vos prix de votre licence
elle ne vaut rien
début de discussions
c'est sûr que les accords fait dans ce
contexte même qui quand ils se font dans
le cadre de la loi sont rarement des
accords qui amène à une juste
rémunération
et donc je veux ici vous dire que nous
continuerons d'évaluer et d'améliorer la
mise en oeuvre afin que ce serait bien
une juste rémunération des droits
d'auteur et des droits voisins auxquels
nous avons qui sont les autorités
françaises et européennes ont donc
continuer de regarder cet accord nous
compléterons si besoin est et nos textes
français et européens pour aller au bout
de la volonté qui fut la nôtre et
demeure la nôtre la juste rémunération
de droits d'auteur et des droits voisins
l'autorité de la concurrence a encore
sanctionné google à hauteur de 500
millions d'euros l'obligeant à négocier
avec les agences et les éditeurs de
place de presse c'est une belle victoire
mais le chemin est encore long je veux
ici vous dire que nous continuerons
collectivement d'être vigilant autorités
compétentes donc en france et en europe
mais aussi
au gouvernement et législateurs pour ne
rien céder de ce combat je suis aussi
heureux qu'après avoir obtenu de
l'europe la contribution de ces grandes
plateformes on appelle parfois lesquels
fabrega femme par facilité au
financement de la production française
nous ayons obtenue dans le cadre élargi
de l' ocde et dans quelques semaines
avec une déclinaison européenne très
forte un accord aussi pour les taxer et
donc contribuer au financement du bien
commun ce qui est important pour que
nous puissions demander que tous ces
acteurs exerce bien leurs
responsabilités plus largement les deux
grandes directives qui sont en cours de
discussion et de finalisation sur
lesquels nous allons mettre l'accent
dans le cadre de cette présidence
française la directive sur les marchés
et la directive sur les contenus
respectivement dit dma et des usa vont
nous permettre de construire le début
d'un cadre de régulation européen inédit
qui va permettre d'aller beaucoup plus
loin en particulier sur le modèle
économique mais aussi sur la régulation
des contenus et la responsabilité
d'aider plateforme est donc d'aller dans
le sens de ce que vous évoquez
comme vous le voyez sur tous ces sujets
nous sommes rendez-vous notre modèle
historique mais aussi à l'avant garde de
ce combat européen et international pour
pouvoir justement
bâtir les conditions d'un modèle
économique viable c'est à dire qui
rémunère de manière juste ce qui est
construit par les journalistes les
photographes l'ensemble des créateurs
des dessinateurs et de toutes celles et
ceux qui contribuent à la presse enfin
j'ai souhaité que 2022 soit l'année
d'un combat j'allais dire culturel qui
réhabilite l'information
documenté éclairé fondée sur un travail
d' enquête
et qui au diktat de l'émotion que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure oppose le
travail du temps long qui aurait une des
algorithmes dont je soulignais les
risques tout à leur oppose celui de
l'esprit critique ou pour reprendre la
formule de ladite commission que je vais
évoquer l'esprit de méthode c'est
pourquoi nous avons installé à l'automne
dernier vous le savez une commission
intitulée les lumières à l'ère numérique
présidée par le sociologue gérald
bronner dont ce matin rapport n'a été
rendu et j'étais accompagné de plusieurs
membres du gouvernement dont la ministre
ici présentes et plusieurs
parlementaires
les présidentes et présidents
d'autorités administratives
indépendantes
parmi les nombreuses recommandations
formulées par ce groupe d'experts pour
lutter contre les fausses informations
essayer d'avancer pour
contrecarrer ce que vous et moi venons
de décrire
pour répondre aux complotisme et à ce
qu'on appelle l'enfermement
algorithmique c'est à dire le fait de ne
jamais être confrontés à des
informations contradictoires ce qui est
aujourd'hui le cas de millions de nos
concitoyens à travers le monde
beaucoup de propositions ont été faites
qui mérite un débat démocratique
approfondie je souhaite que nous
puissions avoir ce débat dans un temps
démocratique que nous connaissons tous
pour ce qui est de la france mais aussi
dans un cadre européen et au delà
évidemment des échéances électorales à
venir
je crois néanmoins que nous serons
collectivement d'accord sur quelques
orientations je veux ici juste donner
quelques
le sont en quelque sorte si raide ce
travail remarquable qui nous a été
rendue ce matin la première s'est
développé l'esprit de responsabilité
les journalistes et directeurs de
publication par formation par éthique
dans le cadre de la loi vous l'avez
parfaitement rappelé tout à l'heure
parce qu'ils inscrivent leur action dans
un cadre établi son responsable je pense
qu'il faut le rappeler à tous nos
compatriotes sont responsables croiser
les sources et peuvent répondre
d'ailleurs de ce qu'ils écrivent devant
le juge
il doit en être de même pour toutes
celles et ceux qui produisent et
diffusent l'information
les plateformes numériques c est ce qu
on appelle les influenceurs les citoyens
aussi qui parfois prennent une place
considérable dans le débat public par le
biais justement de ces nouvelles
plateformes de ces nouveaux réseaux qui
en achetant d'ailleurs de l'axé qui en
le développant par telle ou telle
pratique doivent avoir un cadre de
responsabilité qui est à construire
sinon en quelque sorte vous seriez
placer ce qui est le cas aujourd'hui
dans une situation asymétrique
responsable
d'une information que vous avez à
diffuser parfois contrant ou débattant
avec des acteurs qui eux n'ont aucun
cadre de responsabilité
ils doivent aussi en être de même pour
les médias étrangers autorisés à
diffuser sur le sol français et je le
dis ici avec beaucoup de gravité
nous sommes aujourd'hui nous démocratie
en quelque sorte
parfois naïf en tout cas avec des
anticorps qui ne sont pas tout à fait au
bon niveau pour filer la métaphore qui
fait notre quotidien à tous et toutes
qu'en utilisant le cadre d'information
qui est le nôtre et ceux de notre loi
nous laissons des acteurs de propagande
financé par des régimes autoritaires
étrangers qui ne sont absolument pas qui
ne répondent en aucun cas un régime de
responsabilité ou de déontologie
journalistique informé participer aux
débats comme des journalistes
et donc nous avons une responsabilité
collective à préserver un espace public
où circule l'information libre plurielle
et diverse où chaque citoyen peut être
confronté à une idée et à son opposé
pour cela il faut que le cadre de
responsabilité soit clarifiée et
renforcée compte tenu de ces nouveaux
acteurs
un deuxième grande orientation
nous donner les outils collectivement
pour protéger l'espace informationnel
qui exige vous le savez mieux que moi
professionnalisme et éthiques
nous ne sommes pas naïfs il ne s'agit
pas que de qualité de l'information il
s'agit aussi de savoir nous protéger là
aussi contre des ingérences de
puissances étrangères dans les
intentions sont très clairs et qu'ils
profitent de la pleine liberté que le
relais sont alors même souvent que ces
deux mêmes puissances vous empêche de
diffuser ou d'exercer votre profession
sur leur territoire
commence à se développer à cet égard les
processus d'autorégulation de
certification qui sont portées par vous
même par vos représentants pour
travailler avec les rédactions avec les
journalistes pour aider les citoyens les
acteurs privés les plateformes les
annonceurs les acteurs publics
et régulateurs aussi et pour identifier
les média fiable
fiable parce que le processus de
production de l'information répond à des
critères déontologiques de base et je
dis cela avec une extraordinaire
puissance prudence pardon parce que il
ne revient pas aux pouvoirs publics de
faire ce travail de qualification
le cadre est bien posée par la loi de
1881 mais il y a un travail que vous
avez commencé collectivement et qui
prospère et qui relève d'ailleurs de
même initiative que celle conduite à
l'international que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure qui est un travail de
reconnaissance entre pairs
je crois à la vertu de celui-ci
et je pense que c'est un travail
extraordinairement fécond donc je pense
que chacun doit être mis à sa à sa juste
place j'en suis le garant de là où je
suis et je verrai à ce qu'il n'y ait pas
d'intrusion ne doit pas y avoir
d'intrusion ni de politique ni de
l'administratif ni des pouvoirs publics
dans cette identification mais nous
devons simplement
vous aider par tous on ne peut pas
construire ces mécanismes entre pairs
consistant à fiabiliser et à identifier
les acteurs et la nature de ces
informations
il ya aussi à côté de ça dans le cadre
défini par la loi respectueuse de nos
valeurs et de l'état de droit auquel je
tiens comme vous l'importance de nos
régulateurs qui eux doivent permettre en
particulier
de d'exercer leur contrôle sur
l'indépendance éditoriale de médias
étrangers avant d'autoriser leur
diffusion et de conserver le cadre posé
par nos lois
il faudrait être certain que nous
aurions le jour venu la capacité aussi
de protéger nos médias d'opérations de
rachat hostile ou de phénomènes l'hyper
concentration et je pense que dans les
prochains mois dans un cadre apaisé qui
je pense doit sans doute enjamber les
échéances à venir il est important que
tous ces sujets soient repensées et
reposer compte tenu des évolutions
contemporaines que vous avez décrite et
je vous remercie d'ailleurs de grande
rigueur et de l'esprit d'indépendance et
du courage que vous avez eu à titre
personnel de le faire en tant que
président de la pp et indépendamment de
votre situation de journalistes propre
mais je partage ses préoccupations donc
je pense que nous devons sans doute là
aussi examiner la robustesse de notre
cadre juridique et de le faire sur le le
cadre économique tente en franco
français qu'en regardant aussi les
opérations en internationales qui
peuvent se faire il ya aussi une
dimension de réciprocité face à
certaines pratiques contre lesquelles il
me semble que nous devons pouvoir
collectivement nous défendre quand nous
devons faire preuve d'une grande
vigilance une fois l'autorisation
d'émettre données dans les contenus
diffusés et donc on voit bien que nous
avons un cadre de régulation qui est
sans doute là aussi à améliorer a amendé
pour permettre de continuer de protéger
le cadre auquel vous appartenez auquel
vous tenez tant
c'était la seconde orientation sur ces
outils pour protéger l'espace
informationnel la troisième et dernière
orientation que je voulais retenir de ce
travail
c'est de former davantage
nos enfants l'ensemble de nos acteurs à
l'esprit critique ou comme je le disais
plus tôt à l'esprit de méthode face à
ces transformations mais je crois
beaucoup à cette idée l'école doit
instruire elle doit aussi faire des
républicains comme disait puissant et
élever des citoyens et donc développer
la capacité à un recul à la recherche de
sources à l'esprit critique cet esprit
critique où cet esprit de méthode je
veux le dire ici avec beaucoup de force
parce que nous sommes tous des enfants
de la république et nous avons à faire
ce distinguo ça n'est pas le relativisme
qui conduite au complotisme
si on confond ces deux notions alors on
construit on déconstruit progressivement
la citoyenneté au rang des citoyens
malheureux le relativisme c'est un
comportement qui voudrait dire que il
n'ya plus de vérité que tout se vaut et
qu'à la fin si je suis plus confortable
avec une vérité qui est celle de mes
amis je peux me réfugier et cela conduit
au complotisme l'esprit critique où
l'esprit de méthode consiste à dire que
la vérité n'est pas dite par un seul
mais qu un travail méthodique que ce
travail qui consiste par la vérification
des sources le croisement de celle ci la
contradiction des arguments le débat
éclairé je peux me rapprocher en tout
cas construire un chemin qui mène à une
vérité peut-être d'ailleurs provisoire
mais une vérité
cet esprit de méthode c'est celui qui
permet de
construire la démocratie et l'action
efficace et durable en démocratie
et il est menacé par deux choses il est
menacé par des puissances autoritaire et
par la manipulation de l'information est
tout un champ en quelques sortes de
pratiques qui viennent empêcher
le rapport à la contradiction la
construction de cette contradiction
l'accès aux sources c'est ce qu'on voit
dans certains pays qui vous empêche de
faire leur travail qui masque les
sources qui voudraient mettre en place
une forme de révisionnisme historique
d'êta ou c'est aussi ce qu'on voit à
travers des pratiques du secteur privé
qui bâtissant des algorithmes manipulant
l'accès à l'information fausse en
quelque sorte la possibilité de
construire cet esprit de méthode
est donc la première menace elle est
bien là dans la puissance de ces acteurs
économico-politique la deuxième menace
je le disais dans l'effondrement de tout
rapport à la vérité le doute absolu qui
en quelque sorte fini par justifier
l'ignorance ou les pratiques du pire et
ça aussi nous le voyons et qui consiste
à parachever les transformations à
l'oeuvre puisque il fait totalement
triompher d'émotion puisque plus rien
que rien n'a de valeur puisque tout se
vaut puisqu'il n'y a plus aucune vérité
puisque on n'est jamais sûr des faits
puisqu'on ne croient plus en personne
je décide de croire en qui je veux
je fais ce qui me plaît
et je bâtis mon comportement sur une
série d'émotions de préférence je me
réfugie dans des bulles notre
responsabilité à tous et par l'éducation
la responsabilisation ce travail de
défendre l'esprit critique où l'esprit
de méthode qui seul fait des
républicains et des citoyens
cette méthode c'est celle qui est au
coeur de votre travail et c'est celle
qui permet seule à une démocratie
d'avoir un débat éclairé et à nos
compatriotes de pouvoir s'exprimer dans
ces débats
c'est pourquoi je suis aussi favorable à
ce que nous inventions un nouvel
enseignement civique tout au long de la
scolarité obligatoire part variable
d'ajustement d'autres matières comme
c'est trop souvent le cas mais un cadre
stable un sanctuaire où l'on apprendrait
aux jeunes français l'esprit des
lumières où l'on inculqué les valeurs
universelles défendues par la france où
l'on enseignerait au fond
je le dis ici avec beaucoup de gravité
ce qu'on pourrait finir par appeler
aujourd'hui
la précarité de la démocratie et des
valeurs qui sont les nôtres
nos générations sont en train de
redécouvrir les démocraties précaires
et donc nous avons à nous réarmer pour
les défendre
voilà quelques unes des grandes
orientations que je tire de ce rapport
et je ne veux pas ici être trop long
mais il y assure la question des
algorithmes en particulier j'ai des
propositions très forte et nous aurons
collectivement à avoir des débats sans
doute des régulations
ces plateformes sont des biens communs
notre recherche doit pouvoir avoir accès
à leurs données à leurs mécanismes de
construction à leurs algorithmes sans
quoi nous sommes tous
les fournisseurs ou les utilisateurs de
mécanismes plus puissants que nous et
qui nous manipulent et donc nous aurons
acheminés pour rebâtir cet esprit des
lumières dans le numérique mais comme
vous le voyez qui est au coeur du
travail qui est le vôtre mesdames et
messieurs une nouvelle fois bonne année
à chacune et chacun d'entre vous vous
aurez dans le moment que je viens de
décrire et dans un contexte sanitaire
qui demeurera dégradé je l'espère -
qu'aujourd'hui contraint la mission
difficile d'informer nos compatriotes
sur ce qui s'est imposé comme le rendez
vous démocratique majeur de notre nation
l'élection présidentielle
vous le ferez je le sais avec l'esprit
de sérieux le sens de l'intérêt général
le discernement qui caractérise votre
profession en artisan minutieux bien
loin de l'affadissement et de la
standardisation que la frénésie des
temps veut parfois imposée en citoyen
aussi attaché à ce que chacun puisse à
partir d'une pluralité de points de vue
se forger son opinion et décidé
comme je suis optimiste pour la france
je suis optimiste pour la presse tous
les combats que j'ai évoqués nous les
mènerons avec force et nous les
emporteront
je relisais dans ce contexte et
l'actualité qui est la nôtre durant la
fin d'année dernière un texte d'emile
zola
à la maison duquel j'étais avec
plusieurs d'entre vous d'ailleurs en fin
d'année dernière
texte d'emile zola sur le journalisme il
écrivait c'était en 1894 à cette presse
que de mal on en dit il est certain que
depuis une trentaine d'années elle
évolue avec une rapidité extrême toute
similitude avec la période que nous
vivons est fortuite et
zola d'ajouter et c'est alors qu'on se
demande devant cette exaltation de la
vie publique si il y à un bien ou un mal
phys au delà de conclure on a désiré
savoir parfois ce que je pensais de
cette opinion
ma réponse c'est que je suis pour et
avec la presse est un peu plus loin au
bout de toutes les manifestations de la
vie dans le sang et les ruines il y a
quelque chose de grand
je suis comme l'auteur de j'accuse il ya
des turpitudes du quotidien je suis
lucide sur les défis et les évolutions
de votre secteur
mais il ne dépend que de nous mêmes à la
fin de tout cela de voir et de vouloir
quelque chose de grand
je suis donc très optimiste pour vous et
pour nous merci pour votre engagement
vive la république et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
et voilà pour l'adresse des voeux des
manuels macron à la presse on retrouve
tout de suite notre grand reporter
régissent le sol us
bonjour régissent cette allocution d'
emmanuel macron s'est ouverte sur des
propos préliminaires d'olivier dubost le
président de l'association de la presse